so we're asked to graph y is equal to
three times sine of one half x
minus two in the interactive widget and
this is the interactive widget that you
would find
on khan academy and it first bears
mentioning how this widget works so this
point right over here
it helps you define the midline
the thing that you can imagine your sine
or cosine function oscillates around
and then you also define a neighboring
extreme point either a maximum
or a minimum point to graph
your function so let's think about how
we would do this and like always i
encourage you to pause this video and
think about how you would do it yourself
but the first way i like to think about
it is what would a regular just
if i if this just said y is equal to
sine of x how would i graph that
well sine of 0 is 0 sine
of pi over 2 is
1 and then sine of pi is 0 again
and so this is what just regular sine of
x would look like
but let's think about how this is
different well first of all
it's not just sine of x it's sine of one
half x so what would be the graph of
just sine
of one half x well one way to think
about it there's actually two ways to
think about it
is a coefficient right over here on your
x term
that tells you how lar how fast the
thing that's being inputted into sine
is growing and now it's going to grow
half as fast
and so one way to think about it is your
period is now going to be
twice as long so one way to think about
it is instead of getting to this next
maximum point at pi over 2
you're going to get there at pi and you
could test that if you
at when x is equal to pi this will be
one half pi
sine of one half pi is indeed equal to
one
another way to think about it is you
might be familiar with the formula
although i always like you to think
about where these formulas come from
that to figure out the period of a sine
or cosine function
you take 2 pi and you divide it by
whatever this coefficient is
so 2 pi divided by 1 half is going to be
4 pi and you can see the period here we
go
up down and back to where we were over 4
pi
and that makes sense because if you just
had a 1 coefficient here your period
would be
2 pi 2 pi radians you make one circle
around the unit circle is one way to
think about it
so right here we have the graph of sine
of one half x
now what if we wanted to instead think
about three times
the graph of sine of one half x or three
sine
one half x well then our amplitude is
just going to be three times as much
and so instead of our maximum point
going from instead of our maximum point
being at one it will now be at
three or another way to think about it
is we're going three above the midline
and three below the midline so this
right over here is the graph of three
sine of one half x now we have one thing
left
to do and this is this minus two so this
minus two is just going to shift
everything down by two so we just have
to shift everything down so let me shift
this one down by two
and let me shift this one down by two
and so there you have it notice our
period is still four pi
our amplitude how much we oscillate
above
or below the midline is still three and
now we have this minus two
another way to think about it when x is
equal to zero this whole first term is
going to be zero
and y should be equal to negative two
and we're done